هذا ما تبقى من موقعي تجمع القوات الروسيه
في اقليم دونيت جنوبيه اوكرانيا تقول
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان سته صواريخ
هيمارس اطلقها الاوكرانيون على الموقع
انتشار مؤقتا لاحدى وحدات القوات المسلحه
الروسيه بالقرب من بلده مكيفكا في جمهوريه
دوميتك الشعبيه
روسيا المكان المستهدف يقع الى الشرق من
مدينه دنيانيه حيث تصيطر القوات الروسيه
ليس بعيدا عن الخط الفاصل بين الجانبين في
اقليم دونيت في الاقليم يتواصل القتال
ويتنازع الطرفان السيطره رغم اعلانه
جمهوريه مستقله اعترفت بها موسكو
الذي توفي الهجوم هو استخدام منظومه هاي
مارس الامريكيه وصلت لمنظمه الى القوات
الاوكرانيه الصيف الماضي حينها توعد وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني الجنود الروس بان الصيف
قد يكون الاخير لهم تتميز المنظومه بدائره
استهداف واسعه نسبيا تعطي القوات
الاوكرانيه يدا طولا خصوصا عند خطوط
التماسي بين الجانبين الميزه الاهم فيها
مارسي دقه التوجيه هكذا تعطي هايما ارسل
الاوكرانيين المسافه والدقه في انما لم
يتوقف الاوكرانيون عند حدود البلاد وخطوط
التماسي داخلها ضربات الاسبوع الماضي
تستهدف قاعده عسكريه في العمق الروسيه
اليوم تقول السلطات الروسيه انهم سياره
اوكرانيه استهدفت مقاطعه بريانكا الحدوديه
كذلك تحديدا محطه الطاقه ليتوقف التيار
الكهربائي للاثني عشر ساعه كما قال حاكم
المقاطعه الروسيه هكذا تنقل القوه
اوكرانيات ومشاهدا انقطاع الكهرباء في كيب
والمدن الاخرى الى المدن الروسيه تتهم
روسيا باستهداف البنيه التحتيه الاخرانيه
مسيرات ايرانيه الصنع تملا سماء اوكرانيا
تستهدف محطات الطاقه ليصبح الشتاء اكثر
صعوبه على الاوكرانيين وان كانت صور
الظلام لا تقارن بين الجانبين فان الحرب
تاخذ من عطف اكثر توتر وترا يغلق الطرق
امام الحلول الدبلوماسيه في المدى المنظر
على الاقل